Jason Momoa has been playing DC's
Aquaman for more than five years but
with a new creative team behind a DC
Movie Machine rumors are swirling that
he might be about to double dip with
anti-heroes like Venom Deadpool and
Black Adam Making Waves at the box
office with their unorthodox methods and
offbeat senses of humor it's natural to
wonder whether some of the other
anti-heroes of the comic book world are
going to get feature films of their own
now more than ever a film centered on a
filthy mouth Bounty Hunter like Lobo
seems like a distinct possibility if
only an actor can be found to embody the
character's hyper-violent nature and
unusual fondness for profanity who has
the X Factor necessary to bring Lobo
from the page to the screen one obvious
choice thanks to his experience playing
the barbaric Khal Drogo and Game of
Thrones is Jason Momoa there's only one
problem Mamoa is already busy in the DC
extended Universe playing Aquaman but
that can't stop fans from dreaming about
Momoa and the role of Lobo whether or
not such an arrangement would ever be
practically possible and if you take a
look at some recently released fan art
depicting Momoa in the role you have to
admit to make a good fit and it seems
evident that he'll be able to make the
ultimate bastich as entertaining on the
screen as he is on the page fans are
right to speculate on who might portray
Lobo on the big screen and Jason Momoa
was recently asked about the possibility
in a comicbook.com interview to promote
his upcoming Slumberland film on Netflix
James Gunn set to take over the film
wing of DC Comics posted a picture of
Lobo on his official Mastodon account
leading some to assume that a lobo
feature film is in the works when asked
about it Momoa didn't shut down the
prospects his duties as Aquaman
notwithstanding having recently
discussed an upcoming dream project
within the DC extended Universe Momoa
doesn't deny that such a project could
involve Lobo huh well everyone knows I'm
a big comic book fan and so the comic
that I collect the most and I have every
comic there is you can do your research
and find out what that is I love you too
could this be a reference to Lobo what
audiences accept two DC Superheroes
portrayed by the same actor across
multiple projects with Lobo and Aquaman
get to fight each other none of these
questions are answered by the excellent
piece by fan art Maestro boss Logic on
Instagram depicting Momoa as Lobo but it
looks pretty cool anyway the picture
shows Momoa in full logo gear and makeup
and the comments seem mostly
enthusiastic about the prospect even
with the Atlantis size conflict of
interest the casting would represent
boss logic's rendition of Jason Momoa
and the role of Lobo looks good and true
to the original character but it also
calls to mind another Jason Momoa comic
book movie project that never came to
fruition the crow the crow was famously
first adapted for a movie in the 1990s
with Brandon Lee as a titular gloomy
crime fighter and for a Time Momoa was
attached to the project unfortunately it
didn't happen amamoa even apologized to
fans of the character of his inability
to get the project off the ground
looking at Momoa as Lobo and boss logic
fan art it's difficult not to see the
similarities between both characters
distinctive facial features and laments
that neither momoa's Lobo or momoas to
Crow ever made their way to the screen
at least not yet